Emily Kaufman's going to tell us about
revisiting the exploration exploitation
freedom thank you and thanks for the
invitation I'm glad to be here so the
median bandit problems that I'm going to
talk about what should I do okay sorry
so the mission bandit problem which is
the focus of this talk is often
associated with the need for an
exploration exploitation trade-off so
the first goal of this talk is to
contrast this objective with that of
pure exploration in which we relaxed the
constraint to a Maximizer rewire we was
while discovering the the best arm and
we will see that sampling strategy for
both subjective are quite different
indeed and then I will revisit the
simplest possible approach for solving
this exploration exploitation dilemma
that would consist in first an
exploration phase of possible random
lengths followed by an exploitation
phase in which we would commit to play
the arm that word decided best in the
exploration phase and in a particular
case I'm going to characterize very
precisely the sub optimality of such
approaches but before a quick recap on
the museum bonnet problem also you might
be a familiar with it so it's only a
bunch of arms that are probability
distribution so I'm a as min mu a and
then there is an agent interacting with
these arms and deciding a time sheet who
draw am a tea after which you observe a
sample XT from The Associated
distribution and of course his strategy
for sampling the arms has to be
sequential in the sense that I'm chosen
a time T plus 1 must depend only on the
past shows and arms and the past
observed samples so the generic goal in
such a million valid model is to learn
which arm is best in the sense of the
means we are looking for identifying a
star's arm with highest meaning but this
running constraint can this learning
process can have some constraint and
actually one of the most considered
problem would be that of regret
minimization in which the sample that
are collected are viewed as rewards and
in such a case it makes sense to have a
sampling strategy at
to maximize the reward we get so here in
expectation because of course the
rewards are random and this is
equivalent to minimizing the regret
which is defined as the difference
between the accumulated rewards with an
Oracle that would know in inside the
best Arman so he gets T mu star rewards
- so they expected sum of reward with or
actual strategy and this we write as the
sum over the arm of the gap between the
mean of the best arm and the mean of em
a multiplied by the expected number of
times an arm a has been drawn up two
times so we have this na t notation so
to minimize regret we of course have to
do an exploration exploitation afraid of
so exploration because we need to draw
all the arm to have a kind of an
estimate of the mean but we would want
to focus on the best arm so far because
we have this constraint to maximize the
reward so just to give precise example a
pure exploratory strategy would be
simply to allocate your budget evenly
between arms so this is of course bad
because every suboptimal
arm is through a linear amount of
diamonds of course your regret is linear
and so on the other end of pure
exploitative strategy would be well
first sum per each arm once and then go
with your current estimate of the best
arm so that is if mu at T denotes the
empirical mean of the rewards that you
observed from a then you choose the one
with highest empirical mean and this is
also very bad because we probably t1
minus mu star the first time you draw
the best arm it gives you zero and then
you never play it again so a better idea
would be to mix exploration and
exploitation and the first idea is to
start with exploration and do
exploitation next and so first we
explore the arm uniformly and then so we
commit to the empirical best so far but
what we shall see in this talk is
whatever the stopping world between this
extra asian on exploitation faced this
is not as good as strategy mixing
exploration and exploitation but first
let's go back to the motivation on why
you may want to minimize regret so I'm
going back here to the example of Don
stock and on Monday level clinical trial
indeed the arm would be here some
Bernoulli random variable that would
model the efficacy of a treatment across
patient and then in a medical study one
has to decide for patient T which
treatment a t to give him and in an
ideal world we assume that we directly
observe a response X T equals zero and
one depending on whether the patient is
healed on that and the probability that
is healed is the unknown success
probability of the treatment so in this
framework minimizing regrets amounts to
maximizing the number of patient that
has been here during the study which
makes sense of course from a medical
perspective but what what we also heard
about on Monday that saving past patient
is not the goal of clinical trial so
according to this Belmont report and
indeed the goal might be rather to
support the arm in order to most
efficiently estimate which treatment is
best so you would allocate the treatment
to patient in order for example to
identify as quickly as possible the best
treatment so I don't say I agree but the
idea would be like in early stage
clinical trial you want to find the best
treatment because the idea is then this
treatment will be given to a much larger
population anyways this term is to
introduce the two valid problems that
I'm considering today so I already
talked about the regret minimization
problem in which you have to build a
sampling rule such that given the
horizon T that you may or may not now
the goal is to minimize the regret up to
this horizon and as opposed to this
problem I will introduce a particular
best term a notification problem that I
defined as follows
so first I'm not going to have only a
something rule I'm also going to
introduce a stopping rule so to randomly
stop the experiment when I think I have
identified the best arm and then I
propose a recommendation for the best
arms that I did not buy a hat and then
the goal would be given a risk parameter
data make sure that the probability that
your recommendation is accurate with
probability larger than one minus Delta
while minimizing the expected number of
samples needed to make this
recommendation so they expect it in a
lot of patient you have to involve in
the in the clinical trial so this is one
example of a pure exploration problems
so there are other variant of this in
the literature yeah like do you fix the
budget and want to minimize the
probability of error oh you mean my
simple regret but today I'm going to
talk about this so-called fixed
confidence framework and in this talk
I'm going to present optimal algorithm
for both objective in a problem
dependent sense that is for on any given
mu bandit and stance I will achieve some
optimal rate and then we will discuss at
the end of the talk the performance of
explored and committed strategy so this
strategy trying to use pure expression
tools within regret minimizing
memorizing algorithm and in order to
talk we will focus on simple bandit
instances in which the distribution of
all arms are parameterize by their means
and so for example in the boundary K is
associated to the medical trial example
or we can assume Gaussian distribution
as in the previous as in the previous
talk and so yeah the mother is entirely
parameterized by this vector of mean ok
so let me start by optimal algorithm for
regret minimization that are by now
quite well known but I quickly recap
them so I just remind you that the
regrets can be rephrased in term of this
expected number of drugs suboptimal um
so of course to have no regrets you want
to draw on a little the suboptimal arms
but there is a well-known result from
lion robins that tells you that all the
arms should still be drawn infinitely
many and they give a very precise rate
for this the growth of these drawers of
suboptimal
arm and so this results is expressed in
terms of an important information
theoretic measure so the cubic like
blood diversions between a distribution
of the arms and so we
introduce a notation D of mu mu prime as
the KL divergence between the
distribution with mean mu and the
distribution of mean mu prime so in the
gaussian case this is simply related to
the square gap between the means well in
the boundary case it takes a little more
complex formulation but tyll tyll
explicit and so the liner beans results
tells you that for every uniformly
efficient algorithm so an algorithm for
which the regret would be small on every
problem the expected number of draws of
a suboptimal are a up to time T is
asymptotically lower bounded by log T
divided by so the Kilberg hybrid
divergence between the distribution of
am a and between the distribution of the
beste and so this motivates the
definition of an asymptotically
algorithm that such that for every
bandit instance the expected number of
draws of a is upper bounded by a lot T
divided by D mu a in stock so I'm going
to give you an example of such algorithm
among the well-known family of UCB types
of algorithm so those algorithm are very
simple as I just compute one index for
each arm that happened to be a network
confidence one so the idea is that given
the past observation you have from the
arm you can be lacan you can build
confidence interval on the unknown mean
of each arm and then you act kind of
optimistically by assuming that the true
value that you don't know it the best
possible value and in such a problem you
would pick the arm with largest use and
of course in order to get an
asymptotically optimal algorithm one has
to be careful in how we build the UCB
and here I give you the UCB index that
we'd yield and asymptotically optimal
algorithm so you see that it's not
necessarily explicit but it is built
using the divergence function G that
appears in the lower bond so in the
Gaussian case G is very explicit so you
get exactly the an index that resembles
the famous UCB one algorithm but in the
Bernoulli case you have to compute this
by looking at the function D of MU at K
and then threshold Anita two-level
locked
divided by the number of observations so
this is still efficient to compute and
it can be shown so using a ton of method
and some refinement that this is indeed
an upper confidence bond with
probability of order 1 minus 1 over T
which is roughly what you need for the
analysis of UCB and it had proved that
this algorithm is such that the expected
number of draws alpha sub optimal arm a
up to time T is upper bounded by locti
dividing by the right constant plus a
second order term that I don't it
so we have our optimal algorithm in the
sent I define for the the regret
mutation problem so the best time
notification problem has been a bit less
understood but from four recent results
we have also a characterization in some
regime in with the risk with this world
of what I would call an optimal
algorithm and the idea will be similar
we will try to get a lower bound so this
time on the number of sample needed for
the accurate from recommendation and
then try to have an algorithm matching
the row up okay so first recall that a
best time notification algorithm is
three things so still the sequential
something wrong the stopping rule and
the recommendation rule and as we don't
know you we will want that for every
possible bandit instance in our class so
Bernoulli Gaussian bandits and so forth
the probability that the recommendation
is indeed the true best almond disease
model is larger than one minus Delta and
so with our language a we recently gave
a lower bound on the sample complexity
so the expected number of samples needed
of every Delta pack algorithm telling
that to the some complexity is more than
T star of MU times roughly log whenever
Delta where T style of music is
characteristic number of samples
actually can be expressed using some the
solution of some optimization problem so
here we have the supremum of the all
probability vectors overall proportion
of draws somehow and here we have the
infimum over all bandit model lambda for
which the optimal arm would be different
of this COIs
and this quantity can be interpreted as
we shall see later as a cost of
transportation but what is also
interesting when we look at the proof as
R is read out that I'm not going to give
here or sweets three lines we can see
that here if you take the egg max so if
we define as this vector W star of MU it
can actually be interpreted at the
optimal proportions of draw of the arm
in the tank that any algorithm that
would match the lower bound
should satisfy the following so the
proportion of times ma has been wrong
should be afforded this context here w
star mu and we also actually proposed an
efficient way to compute the solution
that simply resort to solving a 1d
optimization problem with with standard
techniques
okay and what I'm going to show you now
is simply so because we hadn't
identified the optimal proportion we can
artificially design an algorithm that
will force the proportion of draw to
converge to to this target committee and
that's what we do here with this
tracking yeah
well you have to consider all the
possible bandit model in which the
optimal arm is not is not the same and
for example this imp you can say that it
is a minimum of the in when arm to
become larger than I am one I'm sorry
become lashes and a no arm one and each
of this optimization problem you have a
closed-form solution no because you
don't satisfy this constraint you have
to change the Gemara because in muse of
team arm is one and you have to propose
a lambda in which the optimal arm would
be 2 or 3 or something this is all the
alternative okay so now building on this
the solution of this optimization
problem that we can compute for all mu
actually we propose to look at time T at
your current estimate of all the mean of
the arms of mu hat and then we start you
start by looking whether there is an arm
that has been grown less than square
root T if this is the case then you draw
it so this is some kind of forced
exploration that will guarantee that the
the empirical means are actually going
to converge to they are true values and
if there is no under Explorer arm which
shows the arms that maximizes the
difference between T W star of mu hat
and the number of minors and number of
drawers of a so it means that we are
going to compute the vector W star for
our empirical mean at it from so we have
this procedure to be to be efficient and
it's not too easy to see that this
tracking we will make sure that the
fraction of drawers of a is going to
converge to the target the value star mu
and so finally the algorithm that we
propose we call it track and stop
because it is based on this tracking
something rule and fall so stopping
world so I didn't want to give too much
detail but our idea is to use generalize
like huge ratio test so the idea is that
we stop when for the current and figure
we would reject the hypothesis that it
is different from all do the other arms
and it turns out that this stopping
statistic and also can be written in the
following way so this is not the way we
use to really compute compute it because
there is also of course an efficient way
to to compute it but this is just to
draw the link with optimization problems
that appeared in the Ramadan because you
understand that if this is close to your
W star then this quantity will be close
to your your t star so this is just to
give the idea of why why it works and of
course when we stop I don't say it but
you recommend empirical test um
and what we proved is that so when Delta
is small so expected number of sample
used by this algorithm is of order T
star multiplied by log whenever Delta so
analysis is asymptotic but if you
actually run the track and stop
algorithms that you can do you realize
that it's helping the the sample and
complexity of any fixed budget algorithm
I know so it's also practical also we
have some progress to make in a in a
clean analysis I would say okay so to
wrap up on the difference between these
two these two setting we saw that so
algorithm for regret minimization and
the particular based on notification
problem I consider quite different
because if you look at the sampling
strategy for a regret minimizing
algorithm the fraction of draw of any
suboptimal arm is going to tend to 0
because the optimal arm is massively
drawn and those are only drawn of order
log T whereas for best time notification
the fraction of draw is going to
converge to 0 optimal proportion and you
can visualize this in a picture in which
I represent so the end of the run of the
Klu CB algorithm on the on the left here
you can see the number of time each arm
are drawn and the confidence interval
you can build with these samples and you
see that the regret miniaturizing
algorithm has a very good estimate of
the best arm but very poor estimates of
all the other whereas here I took some
best time notification algorithm
we see that all the reading are some
told much more and also in terms of
theoretical guarantee actually the
optimal regret rate has a very explicit
form in terms of some of inverse cubicle
area divergence whereas in the best
emulsification we also had an
information theoretic complexity term
but it needs to resort to an
optimization problem that has no
closed-form in in general even in the
Goshen case okay so despite this these
differences I no want to answer the
following question so can pure
exploration tools be used within regret
minimizing algorithm and this bring me
to the last part of this talk in which
we are going to discuss the performance
explored and commit strategy
so first sorry to disappoint you but I
mean I'm going to go back to a very
simple case in which there will be only
two arms and I will assume that yama
Goshen with non-violence one so in that
case the kickback lie blow divergence is
simply a function of the gap and so the
complexity of the problem is fully
characterized by this quantity delta
that is a difference of the two means so
I just recap the optimality results we
have in this particular setting so the
lion woven through a boundary why's that
the regret dividing by lochte is lower
bounded by two divided by delta whereas
up to the optimal rate for best time
notification is that if you want to
Delta pack you will need a number of
sample of order a divided by delta
squared log whenever Delta and also if
you look at optimal algorithm for best
emulsification you can also see that
they they need only to sample the um
uniformly this is very specific to the
Gaussian caste and hence it makes sense
to consider this Explorer then commit
strategy a strategy that would start by
uniformly sampling the arm up to a
certain stopping rule then commuting to
some arm you release the best so far and
playing this arm until the end of the
budget so this is how I define an etc'
strategy
and actually the it's pretty easy to
give an upper bound on the regret of
such strategy so here I will assume that
mu 1 is larger than nu 2 in that case
the regret is simply to get multiplied
by the expected number of drawers of the
suboptimal armor 2 and the suboptimal
arm has been wrong half of the time
during the exploration phase and then if
you commit to this arm you draw it until
the end of the budget so this is a equal
to the number of drawers of 2 and hence
the regret is upper bounded by Delta V
divided by 2 multiplied by the
expectation of the stopping rule plus 2
Delta multiplied by the probability of
around commit so then a natural
candidate for such an algorithm would be
to use the best identification algorithm
we have so we'd be to use so we take an
algorithm matching the precious bounden
we use the it stopping rule and it's a
recommendation rule and of course we
have to tell which value of Delta we
want and if we choose Delta to be 1 over
G then this term will become the
constant and the expected sample
complexity we said it was a father a
divided by Delta square lock G and so
putting things together we get an upper
bound on the regrets that scales in 4
divided by the italic so this is exactly
twice higher than the lion Robins Robin
so the question now is is this the best
possible way to use to design an exploit
and commit strategy and to get the
answer actually we we have to spend a
little time on lower bound and so I want
to give you a flavor on how we derive
Blue Album for banded problem in this
particular two armed case so the idea is
always that of a change of distribution
so we want to know on something on a
banded model mu well we're going to
consider another bounded model lambda in
which the algorithm is supposed to
behave differently because the optimal
arm is not the same in the to model and
if we fix if we look at some stopping
time such that the number of
drawers of um - is a measurable with
respect to the - this typing time then
we can prove we prove the following
lemma that will be then a simple simple
to use to derive vlogabond that says
that so the expected number of drawers
of one x here the kill back lie below
divergence between mu 1 and lambda 1
plus the expected number of rows of 2 x
the kill back library aversions between
mu 2 lambda 2 so this quantity divided
by log T is asymptotically larger than 1
so what does it come from actually
upstairs here this is to be interpreted
as the expectation of the log likelihood
ratio between so the observation under
mu and the observation under lambda and
so all we have to prove is the following
and actually just by definition the
expectation of the log likelihood ratio
is a cubic lie bruh divergence between
so the distribution of the observation
under mu and the distribution of the
observation under under lambda and
thence but by some trick involving the
data processing inequalities that are
free detailed in this paper by ovarium
you can see that this is smaller than
the binary relative entropy between so
the expectation under mu of Z and the
expectation under lambda of Z for any F
Sigma measurable random variable and
then the idea is to apply this result to
a random variable Z which is a
diffraction of draws of m2 and the model
new has chosen such that arm 2 is drawn
little so this will tend to 0
whereas in the model lambda M 2 is not
the optimal arm so this will turn to 2
and so and then we can look at the
asymptotic behavior on this and we can
show that this is equivalent to lochte
using the uniform efficienty assumption
so it's a it's a kind of a sketch of the
proof but the point is how do we use
this kind of result actually it's pretty
classical to read arrive the line Robins
lower bound from here so the change of
measure that is considered is you take M
2 and you move it just slightly above
one and you apply this result to the
starting time Sigma quality but what I
want to explain is how do you derive
lower bound for eg C strategy this is
actually slightly more subtle so first
we are going to choose a chain of
distribution that is going to move both
M 1 and M 2 somewhere in the middle with
a little shift here so that in this new
problem lambda 2 is now optimal so we
fulfill this constraint of changing the
optimal arm and then if you if we pick
the stopping rule in the lemma to be as
a minimum between us who the stopping
rule of the algorithm and actually upon
stopping we know exactly how many time
we are going to draw arm 2 until the end
of the budget so we have this condition
we have that number the total number of
draws of 2 is measurable with respect to
the filtration F F Sigma and so we can
apply the lemma and here are the two KL
terms they will be equal both to Delta
plus epsilon square divided by 8 then we
can regroup these two and we get to
expectation of our stopping time and
then to get from here another one of the
regret when simply remarks that the
regret is lower bounded by Delta divided
by 2 multiplied by higher so expectation
of the stopping because we have at least
to draw the sub optimal arm during the
exploration phase and so what we prove
is that any etc' strategy has to have is
regret lower bounded by 4 divided by
that and we already said that any
optimal best emulsification algorithm
with Delta equal 1 over T is matching
the bound but actually in the paper we
propose a a slightly better strategy so
so an optimal the best emulsification
will basically stop when the distance
between the empirical mean exceeds some
threshold but here we propose a
modification of the threshold where here
in place of the usual log T we get lot C
divided by the number of observation and
this permits to show the fine result
here in which we go give a finite time
upper bound on the regret
and we're here interestingly we have a T
Delta square and this will help us to
derive also a minimax optimal upper
bound so actually the thing is that when
Delta is small you may not be interested
in this result because it is very large
but what is also true is that the regret
is always trivially upper bounded by
delta x t and so taking the minimum of
this of this two term you can get this
kind of distribution independent result
and here we don't get the usual extra
lock key that we can get if we don't
have this kind of terms in the pavan of
the regret so this is a small best of
both world results because we are
optimal we are matching the lionel beans
right but we have also a good minimax
result because this is a lower bound in
the the minimax
problem okay so to conclude on this et
Cie algorithm actually we showed that in
the simple case of gaussian to unbounded
et Cie are twice at least twice worse
than the best possible Eusebio algorithm
and so the myth is a message for people
doing a/b testing would be I mean if you
have to to product that you want to
present to customer rather are starting
by an a/b testing phase and then always
presenting the best at the end of the
day you should do you see be with your
to product or later okay so this is a
message in a simple bandit problem of
course this has to be extended to bandit
model with more arms and especially I
think it might not be easy to understand
how does the combination of an optimal
destined notification followed by
exploitation compares to optimal
algorithm for regret minimization
because we can give a new problem on the
regret of those algorithm but is very
hard to see at first sight of this
compares to the Ryan Robins optimal rate
and with this I conclude with some
reference thank you
in your forest exploration phase when
you're pulling every arm at the N
squared T times square root of T is that
just any having any sequence that goes
off to infinity or a square I think you
should yeah you should take T to some
power locked you wouldn't be enough and
actually this false exploration phase is
needed because you can find it's not
just a trick for the father's theory you
have to enforce that or Armas drawn
because otherwise sometimes you it
doesn't happen a lot but you can find
the issues if you don't add sufficient
exploration phase
is the last theorem that you presented
different from what Jamie and in the
paper bandit with covariance actually it
might be I'm not sure that you used this
for sure the algorithm is different and
so I know that they they already so I
learned from them that you should have
that here Delta Square to have also the
the minimax right what is for sure
differently that we are matching like an
Robinson there are knots but I am pretty
sure that indeed they get also the root
key with some consulting problems so
here the difference is that we are
minimax optimal but we are also problem
dependent ultimate
let's take em Union